sergio viaja al trabajo y le preocupa
quedarse sin gasolina la cantidad de
gasolina que utiliza para cada parte de
su trayecto tiene una distribución
normal pero la cantidad de gasolina que
utiliza de camino a casa
mariah más las cantidades de gasolina
que utiliza para cada parte de su
trayecto son independientes entre sí
a continuación se muestra el resumen de
estadísticas para la cantidad de
gasolina que sergio utiliza en cada
parte de su trayecto así que cuando va
al trabajo utiliza una media de 10
litros de gasolina y tiene una
desviación estándar de 1.5 litros cuando
regresa a casa también utiliza una media
de 10 litros pero la desviación estándar
en este caso es más grande es de 2
litros supón que sergio tiene 25 litros
de gasolina en el tanque y quiere viajar
del trabajo a su casa cuál es la
probabilidad de que serbio se quede sin
gasolina esto es bastante interesante
tenemos la distribución para la cantidad
de gasolina que utiliza para viajar al
trabajo y a casa y nos dicen que ambas
son distribuciones normales
aquí nos preguntan sobre el total de
gasolina que él utiliza para ir al
trabajo y regresar a casa así que
necesitamos encontrar una distribución
total que llamaremos trabajo más casa si
tenemos dos variables aleatorias que
pueden describirse con una distribución
normal y definimos una nueva variable
aleatoria como la suma de esas dos
variables la distribución de la nueva
variable aleatoria seguirá siendo una
distribución normal y su media será
igual a la suma de las medias de las dos
variables aleatorias así que la media de
trabajo más casa es igual a 20 litros él
utilizará una media de 20 litros para ir
al trabajo y regresar a casa ahora para
la desviación estándar de trabajo más
casa no podemos sumar las desviaciones
estándar de las dos variables pero
debido a que la cantidad de gasolina que
se utiliza para ir al trabajo y para
regresar a casa son variables aleatorias
independientes aquí nos dicen que son
independientes entre sí únicamente por
esta razón es que podemos sumar las
varias
así que podemos decir que la varianza
del viaje combinado es igual a las
varianzas de ir al trabajo y de regresar
a casa
cuál es la varianza de ir al trabajo 1.5
al cuadrado más la varianza de regresar
a casa que es 2 al cuadrado 2.25 4 nos
da 6.25 esta es la varianza del viaje
completo si calculamos la raíz cuadrada
de esto vamos a tener la desviación
estándar del viaje completo que es 2.5
ahora podemos describir la distribución
normal del viaje completo y usarla para
responder la pregunta tenemos una
distribución estándar que luce más o
menos así y sabemos que la media es
igual a 20 litros y queremos saber cuál
es la probabilidad de que sergio se
quede sin gasolina para que se quede sin
gasolina necesita gastar más de 25
litros 25 litros de gasolina están aquí
el escenario en el que sergio se queda
sin gasolina es este a quien necesita
más de 25 litros de gasolina para el
trayecto completo
calculamos esta área de acá podemos usar
una tabla zeta para encontrar en cuántas
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media se encuentran los 25 litros bueno
tenemos 5 litros por encima de la media
vamos a escribirlo la zeta es igual a 25
menos la media 20 entre la desviación
estándar de esta distribución normal
combinada 2.5 lo que es igual a 2 estos
estados desviaciones estándar por encima
de la media o puntaje z de más 2 si en
una tabla zeta
buscamos exactamente dos desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media nos dará
esta área que estoy señalando el área
acumulada por debajo de dos desviaciones
estándar por arriba de la media si a uno
le restamos esta cantidad tendremos el
área que nos interesa veamos la tabla
zeta y busquemos el puntaje z de 2
exacto
aquí tenemos 2.00 y el valor es punto 9
772 lo que nos dice que esta área que
señale es
0.9 7 72 por lo que el área que nos
interesa es 1.9 772 que es igual a punto
0 228 la probabilidad de que sergio se
quede sin gasolina es de 2.28 por ciento